[Music]
that voice you hear is the one and only
Johnathan Abram rookie from the Raiders
who I'm gonna be honest as I sit here
with Brian Westbrook for another edition
of the roundtable here on the left coast
show huh
I mean you're ridiculous right now
why do we call this a roundtable and he
doesn't look round you're coming in here
with a turtleneck you showed out late
because you had a calzone you put me off
and then he I mean you're already coming
for us Brooks neck for questioning
Darius slay be the best quarter of the
NFL cuz he went to Mississippi State so
I don't know if he do you see the video
that I did with him for ditch the
playbook yes yeah behind the camera I
like that yes it moved up that's a good
look I am when I tell you Westbrook that
they were supposed to be able to talk
for a while and then he was gonna go and
like confront them on the third one the
guy was like man the Raiders suck and he
was like in their face yeah the [ __ ] you
do and talk about my Raiders I thought
attitude come out but that's that's what
makes you unique and there are so many
newer things that are not in there that
like like like I kept looking at me like
yeah angry let them go out with the
Raiders nations are loving it right now
because they're like that's Abram Ryder
died how you holding up how is it with
the arm how is it not playing cuz I know
you wanted to play I'm holding no good
holding on by a couple of anchors couple
screws yeah what did we get done um so
told my rotator cuff ligaments and
capsules so they had to go in for
incisions put in basically just put the
muscle back on the bone - so that
happened in the second quarter
yeah and then you play the third the
fourth quarter yeah how'd that feel
you shout up that's the first question I
didn't know so you didn't II know so
like you know how like you popped your
knuckles your hand that's kind of what
you saw it to feel like
and so I kept telling when the corners
like because it just felt weird it felt
like my shoulder was sitting on top of
like where he's supposed to be he will
good it and it's not baking okay
and so it was just like the arm was like
weak so I couldn't really use it so I
just I was like man mm-hmm he just
throws right you just tucked it yeah so
I'm gonna let people in a little secret
of what happened this shoot was the day
after the injury yeah and he came in and
I saw in his face right away and I was
like [ __ ]
and I almost texted him that that night
the Monday night when the game was
against Denver because there was one
play where he missed the tackle and
Phillip Lindsey and I was like that's
weird I was like his right arm just like
his left arm just like fell that was
caught in this up man oh yes Courtland
son he wasn't right you could tell I was
like that looked weird but like he still
drilled a dude later on the game but
yeah like so and and so this is what I
appreciate about John is with that shoot
probably took like two hours he was like
he was like his arm was like limp the
whole time like he couldn't even put a
sweatshirt on so I appreciate him he
manned up that's what you need done guys
man and that's pretty cool I'm wrong
with that I won't go there morning oh
how does it go Mikey oh my god I rolled
over and I looked demographics like yeah
yeah how long is the rehab six more six
months that's a long yeah man
can't do nothing obviously no running
nothing no nothing let's just have to
lay there let them work on areas around
it do else like it's annoying are they
already coming up with like sort of once
you can go how fast you're gonna go they
already kind of figure that out the
rehab process yeah so um starting in
three weeks
so like 4d three weeks is just straight
like massage soft tissue in the next
three weeks I get to sling golf is just
gonna be scout scrap scout rechecks and
stuff like that just try sell pumps
trying to just get the arm some blood
back up in there yeah
it was interesting to me because rap to
the game girden came out and was like he
John's gotta be smarter and in a weird
way you your position the hard-hitting
safety is like the mobile quarterback
yeah we always tell Lamar get out of
bounds we tell Kyler slide with you guys
it's like as I've said in this podcast
to you before the hard-hitting safety is
my favorite position in all of sports
Brian Dawkins Ronny LA it's a dying
breed and so the fact that you're like I
don't need to get shot up I'll play the
second half I'll just hit you with this
one have they already kind of talked to
you about when you get back how do you
maintain you being the dog that you are
but also feels like every time you see
me we talk about it you know he hugged
me but like man I miss you I mean he
just be like remember the best thing is
availability mm-hmm the best ability is
available this I like I love Gruden but
that position hard knock you in the
mouth I'm gonna try to kill you if you
come across the middle that's the
position that players fear I remember
playing against Dawkins obviously in
practice I remember to get a red reading
he wasn't a hard-hitting guy he would
kind of get you he'll hit you then Sean
Taylor was a hard-hitting guy those are
the guys offensive you're like okay we
got a plan around this guy yeah we can't
be affected by that guy because hard
hidden safeties change your outlook that
means receivers don't want to go across
the middle that means running backs
instead of going straight down the line
they got to try to figure out a way to
get to the outside that position has
almost been pushed out of the league by
the rules and different things is going
on but when you had that guy there's
nobody that wants to come in remember
doc is hit Algie couplers in the NFC
Championship game I interviewed he
almost killed that bunny so I
interviewed algae crime this summer was
270 dolphins might have 210 so I'm ready
yeah you're gonna kind of bringing up to
speed a little bit of podcast things I
have always said that my pro player
comparison is ALG ALG Crumpler really I
think I have a similar body to that's
true and I would be like the slow tight
end over the middle where if I got 20
yards people are
but I interviewed algae Crumpler and and
I said how many people talk about and I
didn't even finish the sentence he goes
everybody brings up that hit and he says
the number-one thing that pisses me off
is because I went to him when Dawkins
laid that hit I knew we were gonna win
that game he goes the next play work
down squirt touched here yeah but no one
remembers that because we see the hit we
go oh the game was yeah but that's the
hard hitting safety I don't want you to
lose that but I also want you to be in
the league for a decade
so like I'm right there with Curtin
where I'm like like cuz Gruden's like
[ __ ] kill him but at the same time the
question is do you think it's possible
to get that out of your game because in
my mind
you've been playing like that forever
you can't get that out your mind if
somebody comes towards you and you're
trying to knock your head off right now
like I'm in pain if they needed me to
suit up they not like oh say they needed
me too because they let they let my
pseudo Sunday like coming out this bye
week I would get this shot in it and
y'all would be like he's a maniac and I
would hit people with my left shoulder
mm-hmm cuz it be known I wouldn't feel
like shoulder no in the left cuz I
wouldn't feel it yeah oh you would
actually shot up shoulder as a battering
ram and level with somebody that's it
but that's the attitude you have to have
at that position but that's the attitude
leaders demons their old bro okay and
like I I have seen Bob Sanders leave the
league quickly yeah I have seen Bob
Sanders are small today then John yeah
so Gruden I find to be kind of crazy
just grew didn't think you're crazy yes
that's a mood he loves it though of
course he does yes
he tells me there's no one like me and
he don't want anyone to be like me tone
setters guys that set the tone for the
entire team yeah you put him out there
he's gonna get some I in the mouth just
like in college
you know like I told you when I came
here the first time the guys around me
were like really good guys but you know
every every game they weren't always
just exactly ready to go I definitely
sweat like if they needed somebody to
make sure first women's montes with and
I needed somebody to make a play or you
get everybody going they come you be
like this
and you'd pop that running back on the
on the wheel route oh here running a
bubble with some and I smoke somebody
yeah
and they had the day is this is the
first time in my life because I know you
know where I'm actually that other guy
usually I'm like let him get out there
and smoke people mhm but right now I'm
like yo bro but I also know that like
that's your identity
that's your ID yeah so I don't want to
take them okay get away from that no I'm
not gonna stop until I'm like a glitch I
made when I get today I'm here with a 99
automatic [ __ ] no [ __ ] 99 I want to
get to the point where town you here
stick with me and it clean coming out so
that's your goal that's the life goal
hey until night know people in Madden I
can make this a thing listen when Madden
get me there it's real Wow then I may
start cutting people so the Raiders
three and two in London beat the Bears
were you there for the game I knew you
were in London what was the because I
was going to text you on Saturday and go
hey I hate to tell you but I think you
guys are gonna get smoked tomorrow and I
knew I just want to see how he would
even if he would have suited up this is
what would have happened this guy
probably can't did fall but the the
energy in the locker room before and the
energy in the locker room afterwards
what was that like I mean they put they
parents on the same way we do so you
know I knew the guys and I grow never
ready to play you know they were fired
up know especially you know what
everybody was saying straight from the
officer side you know saying that you
know they had like one of the best front
sevens in the game which they do you
know song hola hello max coming to get
revenge
yeah I don't even know why that was like
a theme it wasn't like you know the
Raiders done him bad gave him what he
wanted so that's actually true yeah he
didn't want to be there no more yes so I
mean the fans look at it in like Oh Jon
Gruden made the worst decision that's
one thing you know giant you know he
talks about we don't want anyone here
who doesn't want to be here they tell me
about the mindset because going into
campy obviously you had the whole
Antonio Brown stuff and what's the
mindset of the team that after all of
that stuff went down
to go out and win three games we get
suspended
you know there has to be something that
Switzer said in my mind it was us versus
the world and I don't care about nobody
else only people I care about Z people
in this locker room we always got we
always need I mean that's all the things
you know that's been the whole thing
from the start you know with a B
situation we practice like we weren't
gonna have him all year summer didn't
matter so it didn't matter so if we got
him there's gonna be the ball it's gonna
be a bonus if we didn't have them okay
we're good
that's the thing that I think the
outside world didn't really count on we
were likely they don't have him then
they don't have a chance
yeah you got to steadily building [ __ ]
without I know even when you go watch
the game against the Bears Tyrell
Williams out doesn't crazy JJ Nielsen
out mm-hmm we had ain't happenin and he
just got cut doing Harris out yeah so I
mean but that's show god bless chase
Daniel huh
what we need to do though I mean I just
me and Josh are pretty close you know
Jane wants yeah so the one thing he
always says is we need to run the
Baltimore he got twenty nine thirty
eight hundred forty three yards because
he's you know I said on Monday show that
I think the Raiders are the most
underrated team I'm not saying that
they're the best team I'm not saying
that they're gonna make the playoffs but
the reason I said it was I think we're
still in this
where's a Antonio mindset the national
media is where I look at the team and I
go for enormous offensive lineman and
you're about to get Gabe Jackson back
and like I don't think the the American
public knows how good Gabe Jackson is
these number one guard in the country
this defensive line that was ridiculed
last year all of them are enormous like
all of those guys are large humans and
they all got something to prove
that's my thing too is the and you know
this the NFL the best team in the worst
team now this year's a little bit
different
have you ever heard the saying don't
poke a sleeping bear sure get him wisely
that's the problem they poked the bear
they woke the bear
mmm so like with the d-line like you say
you know all of those guys all they hurt
they just been poked all offseason 13
sex and I know that their their
defensive line
coach is Buckner and I love him he is
one of the greatest love agitators I've
ever seen like I feel like he lives in
those guys hell he do Louisville but
he's a great coach yes
nasty player nasty but you can tell just
boxing he reads it he lives it he brings
it nasty player got it she didn't want
to face in a hole at all yeah but you
know I was thinking of that really quick
about Buckner the thing I appreciate it
cuz I I knew he was gonna be great on
this hard knocks cuz he was great on all
or nothing with the Cardinals and the
reason I love them the most was in that
Cardinals locker room and they were
making a run they had Dwight Freeney and
Dwight Freeney was like the super vet
and the amount of times on that show
that I would see Buckner sitting back
and Freeney was at the whiteboard
I love coaches that can ride you and at
the same time go this is Dwight [ __ ]
Freeney
tell my men how to do a spin move them
do it like that's good coaching is also
knowing that you don't know everything
I always appreciate that clip it was so
many people that question tell my good
coach Gruden I mean I think a lot of
people said he's a TV guy you know he
inherited a team and won the Super Bowl
things like that there had to be
something a message and well obviously
we saw a lot of it during hard knocks
but there had to be a message more than
that that resit gets kept coming back to
you guys that got you guys over that
hump obviously missing Brown and perfect
and all different things everyone's
doubted you guys I mean he made a bunch
of damn money but there's a message that
coaches have to get over to a team what
was that thing that he said that kind of
clicked in you guys head that said you
know what now we're ready to run through
a wall for this man when he said hanging
the dreams in the nightmares that done
it for me like today everybody got gold
everybody got dreams aspirations they
want to do this and do that but then he
come in he tell you straight up you know
he don't care about any of that he into
nightmares
you got dreams of winning the Super Bowl
being the MVP putting up two in a yard
here in the crushing your dream hmm
he wanted to see you cry he want to see
you walk away disappointed and shocked
cuz we crushed your dreams like that for
me was it like ours yeah yeah it kind of
got me it got the little tingle oh yeah
when that YouTube buddy was going around
yeah I can't even like Express or even
imitate you know how it is coming from
him cuz like just look at that picture
uh-huh like that's him like he's off the
wall like and he's like you know he
means it that's right yeah you guys are
both nuts you guys are both crazy but
him like you guys mean the thing that
you know the team appreciates is you
know you know people say they want to
say about him but he eats sleeps in
brief yeah nothing else nothing else I
don't even think like like his son works
with us in the staff and I can do dude I
don't like it's crazy I don't even think
he acknowledges his family but I know he
does but just looking at it it's like
it's all football right he talks to him
like his strength coach not like his son
is what you're saying
yeah you've never seen them hug no only
you never been like you wanted I don't
seem to have a father-son moment you
know it was the father-son it was
working out [ __ ] yeah I still do the
football day and they're pumping them up
and they're doing curls look like so
like the biggest the biggest fatherhood
thing you've seen is chugger and
spotting just screwed all right good job
I'm out
me me my ah but there's something like
look there's there's this funny thing
where people that have never been in a
locker room and people that have never
dedicated themselves to a craft they
look at like a NFL players job and they
compare it to their job different and
the thing is is like deuce probably
loves it too because deuce doesn't want
to be known as John's son I mean deuce
wants to be a great strength coach and
so in a weird way it's very respectful
but we look at him we go if my dad never
[ __ ] hugged me and only was like
would I go pump
I'd be like something's wrong right now
but that's not my life and I and but I
love that [ __ ] I realize that you two
both have a weird thing with food I
don't know if you know this about Brian
Westbrook this person well it's not
weird so let's just stop there start it
start the conversation correctly this is
not a weird thing he had one of the
worst opinions of all time which was
that real pop peanut butter and
chocolate are a bad combination
in fact he believes are the worst
companies worse yeah what it
is all right so let me just all right
give you my backstory - why hold on I
have this yes
right manager because of Reese's so as a
senior in high school hmm why had a math
teacher just be real his name is because
Eve riddle isn't he's like probably one
of the smartest guys ever in a CT he got
a perfect score coming out of high
school like super genius so and I did
like AP and everything so it's only like
12 of us in the class so he brought
everybody 12 like boxes like to have
little pieces you know it's two in the
pay yes 12 cups a real Reese's Cups not
the soul of real novels it doubles God
bless those but he gave us 30 minutes if
you could eat 12 so it was a total of 24
and 30 minutes he would give you like
$1,000 Wow
no one done it and this man ruined
Reese's Cups for you listen okay she's
out there like about four or five like
packs they taste like saying yeah yeah I
don't have any Theresa I go to get were
them I mean it wasn't it was never my
go-to snack no after day it was just
completely ruined like airheads good man
right here silly string no he was a good
man energy people nobody
if I get Charlie Charlie ain't no peanut
butter this is a good man good man I
don't look back on the show you know
peanut butter jelly sandwiches
none of that I am uncovering the world I
didn't know exist on which so another no
hot sauce well now you've taken it way
too damn far now you're missing South
your like hot sauce this something's
wrong you know let me tell you what you
have a math teacher that made you drink
up thing of the not son ah so I was in
eighth grade and all my friends so one
of my friends boys from 357 mad dog goes
pepper to school it's like one of the
hottest hot sauce in the school has
ruined all food man listen so they
they've been a thousand dollars if I
could drink a tea spoon and go two
minutes without drinking anything what
was dismissive privates now that's a to
a smaller school it was like everybody
putting it on he was
and so man I didn't even get a teaspoon
cuz like we have a spoon so I'll put on
a Dorito chip like covered Dorito chip
et nacho or Cool Ranch it don't even
matter man after like two minutes the
chip was the hot sauce was so hot that
they gave me the day off from school wow
really wow I had to go cry in your mouth
as well I put mayonnaise on my skin I
felt like my skin was burning I was
drinking milk
i clawed the toilet up put icing and had
to sit my ass in him because like my
balls and my ass was on fire
wondering when to read wrapper from from
the hot sauce all yeah and since that
day I have not eaten hot sauce no
buffalo wing no nothing cuz I I think
that people have this so like my eyes in
the toilet not nice man violent you know
that's the dude I believe you I'm not a
hot guy like I liked when I went to my
fiance's awesome and I live one of my
teammates try I got a video of him like
puking for like three hours Jerry Wow
Wow no I don't do that maybe you
shouldn't go with the hottest hot sauce
maybe just like the media stirred a
barbecue I think everybody has a flavor
of food a drink and alcohol that they
had a bad experience with and like for
example I don't eat tropical skittles
the purple pack because when I was like
12 I was not feeling great and I had a
few and I threw up and now whenever I
had that flavor he had a few I had the
same way with Three Olives grape vodka
okay I had too much of it one night and
then like the next morning I was like
walking in the bathroom and I smelled it
because the cap was open patrón patrón
no good are you not at the kill a fan of
tequila it was a long night in Hawaii
for the Pro Bowl good ever since then no
I don't even don't want to smell it that
smell does the smell that get you I love
tequila
bad day bad day for whoever cleaned up
that room so if your other weird thing
is
Salman salmon thing when that happened
on Hard Knocks did you know it was gonna
be a thing that you were gonna have to
talk about on every TV show you go to on
every radio show
there would be t-shirts made we're doing
this video and people are bringing it up
salmon and salmon no no I was gonna turn
into that I really didn't isn't that
funny it it really is but it I'm gonna
taste like I told them this morning what
it originated from it wasn't the fact
that I don't know how to say it you know
I know it's admin you just like to have
conversations that many people think yes
that's why I saw his brain teasers
so my grandpa that's well he's do brain
teasers so he sacks me like are you a
smart American or a dumb American I
should be like Smarties but I put your
hand on your chin like this is this
brain teaser you know my thing is you
know I'm always looking into you know
like what what makes this right you know
everybody say oh it's the English
language
who made that right so I looked it up
and I think I have an answer for you all
right give me that I think cuz I don't
think anyone's probably giving you the
answer no one is OK my dad still says
Salman though I'll tell you that my dad
you're definitely not the only my dad
said that so you're not the only one
yeses so the silent L was introduced at
a time I looked it up in the English
language where there's words like debt
which there's a B in there yeah Island
there's an S in there there are certain
letters that were known as quote
historical letters and that they would
be silent but people that were very
interested in the English language
wanted to put in these words so that you
knew the origin of the words because
there's a lot of like roots of words or
stuff where you can trace that back the
etymology of the word and go this
derives from this and this comes from
this part of the world a certain time
and so the L apparently was put into a
lot of words like could would should
because they all came from assert and I
don't know if it's Latin I don't know
what it is but apparently it was put
into those words so that you knew where
they came from that's why people when
they're doing the spelling bees are
always asking what was the country of
origin thright yeah I feel like I may
have finally given you the reason but
then is
I think if you go back to the Latin
language and other word come from who
made them make that right well I think
the thing that you settle down to is is
like the King James Bible okay we had an
issue with religion in this world for a
long time where a lot of people didn't
know how to [ __ ] read and so they do
is as all these like corrupt religious
people get out there and be like God
actually wrote that you should give me
all of your money and people couldn't
read and so you know the the printing
press in Gutenberg and then we can
translate it
somebody did at one point people sat
around and came up with language I mean
what I laugh about is like the first
time I got high it was like why is why
is it called water and you're like whoa
why is it what is my green your blue and
your reds my purple you're like whoa and
like I feel like I need to take you to
like a library and we're just gonna dive
into this and we're gonna figure out who
invented language but it comes from a
damn you know it's kind of like I still
look at that as you know you know
certain people be like oh I'm writing
your own who made that one person right
because that one person now is what's
known as this is what's right with you
yeah and so if you say something else is
wrong hey just like I say that you're
both crazy for not liking peanut butter
and jelly I could be absolutely wrong
you are wrong I would the thing that I
agree about you is you're you're like
the you're like your daughter
you're gonna go why why and then a lot
of times people are like I don't know
yeah and so they dismiss it or they or
they just say all right is wrong yeah
but I don't even think you're right on
this but I do think that you're bringing
up the interesting point of like why
with the reasoning people people go it's
salmon cuz it's salmon yeah but they'll
never look up where did the Cylon L cuz
they don't know that's the thing you
just you just accept it but you never
know that's what you do what your kids
are ones do you have hmm what other ones
do you have that people get frustrated
about where or stuff like that or brain
teasers or anything alright so yes man
we're going to the cup alright so you
have 40 people on the plane
okay the plane crash every single person
dies yes it was one survivor how
there's not everybody died no I said
survivor say one more time
you got 40 people on the plane mm-hm
every single person died yeah there was
a person in the plane the rest were on
the plane no damn the pilot no 40 people
in the playing everybody died one person
survived he wasn't only person to one
person survived how he wasn't on the
plane
yes he was on the plane yes all right so
what's the answer he was married he
survived you got 40 people on the plane
every single person I like that one I
like that way all right so I want to do
a little brain teaser for you that was
like that was a good one though that was
a good John is you know how people have
dad jokes yeah John has grandfather joke
yeah that's what it is
you are a grandfather in spirit mm-hmm
and that's why you play like you're in
the 1920s yeah cuz you're a grandfather
I'm gonna say a guy's name an Instagram
person hit me up CJK 2 6 3 5 and he made
me notice something and I'm gonna play a
little game with you here I'm gonna say
the name of a great player you tell me
their number Jerry Rice 80 Terrell Owens
1881 Randy Moss 1884 84 any were 18 -
yeah but 84 84 all right so now now some
current guys Julio Jones 11 Michael
Thomas 13 Mary Cooper 19 Davante Adams
1877 all right let's go back at a time
all right Michael Irvin 88 88 Chris
Carter
oh no 180 80 this is a Raiders one I
don't expect either Jack Youngblood now
85
let's go current debt all right DeAndre
Hopkins Dan Larry Fitzgerald 11 do you
see what I'm doing here yeah every great
wide receiver in the NFL right now is in
the 11s between 11 and 10 and 19 and
back in the day you always were the
1880s right can you name the two wide
receivers that I think are like good
- possibly great that are actually in
the 80s in the NFL
all right now yeah that's how crazy it
is yeah
we grew up in a time where I everybody
oh-hoh 84 like Antonio Brown but he's
not playing that plan so that's the
biggest loss of a Antonio Brown one of
them is on the Browns yeah daughter's
name
Jarvis Landry is 80 and one of them's on
the Bengals mmm
Tyler Boyd that's what I mean that's
that's all you got those are the two
best 80 wide receivers in the NFL we I
just I'm sure there's been articles
written about this I don't know when it
happened I don't know if you can help me
because you're young if it's just like
kids playing seven-on-seven and like
thinking the numbers are cool how did
this happen and no one's been paying
attention for one the league back in the
day prohibited it so if your wide
receivers you had to be in 80s right
when they changed that rule so now you
see it comments a lot days that's the
problem college yessum you guys because
alignment we're number six and the guys
like that receiver you know you were
single digits mm-hm so like oh do went
from 3 to 13 right Julio was in 11 all
the time yeah what were the old miss
guys like DK I met Ken Brown he was in
1d K was in 14 he's usually in college
your best player where where is the
single digit yeah so like a Marco P were
not like 80 no I was thirty thirty okay
so I hey I was supposed to be number
five but not the guy at the spring game
so I had to keep 38 as a punishment and
and I just kept whacking people and then
it was like no like 38 at killer so yeah
in the spring game he knocked the guy
out that's how he's supposed to do
that's what he does
as a parent a da have you not noticed
that's what he does not speak well he
got in trouble because I didn't know he
went to sleep yeah so and apparently he
doesn't learn his lesson I mean I didn't
know like I didn't know I'm not the guy
called same thing like when I hit him it
was just like all I gave him was like a
little flip I just like bang on and when
I hit him it was just like it was the
hit was like one easy as his error it
was like I went through him to smooth
out yeah I still think the biggest hit
that no one ever talks about is the
biggest hit I think is Sean Taylor
in the Pro Bowl Brian Morman the punter
Thunder yeah he smoked him that is like
your energy
he ran Burton play that's it yeah in the
Pro Bowl everyone's the everybody relax
yeah Ted yeah killing kill but I just
thought that was interesting and I
appreciate the guy saying can you he
asked me name the best wide receiver the
eighties the NFL and I was like Travis
Kelce know and it's it's just like even
even old ass Larry Fitzgerald's 11
mm-hmm see they hang a lot you got a
good point yeah it might be the Kittel
yeah that all right you ready to get
into the jar yeah I have eight random
questions in here yeah some of them are
about life some of them are weird some
of their robot football let's get in
there you go first to pull one and we
want you to do it in the voice of Jon
Gruden oh and you know how to do his
voice but just try all right John which
at least posters or on your wall when
you were in middle school nice and I'm
gonna let Brian Westbrook into this
first
who did you have Wow Michael Jordan that
was it Michael Jordan there was only one
I think I might have had a Walter was
the poster he was dunking on somebody's
fryer you know the one where he's might
have been the foul line double dutch
hula hooper oh but what are the best
high schools in the country just one of
the best cars in the country should have
played it was a no bath huh yeah but I I
had that I had the Jordan free throw
dunk above my then yeah I also had an
Iverson poster where it was like when
high school Iverson was a league bro
really I grew up with Iverson yes I grew
up with you we've talked about this oh
[ __ ] crazy what year did you graduate
high school
Oh for what you know I was doing it Oh
for yeah you were you were helping the
Eagles get to the grown man stuff keep
going um and then I had the other poster
I had was the Michael Jordan poster of
I've missed a thousand like 10,000 shots
you missed a thousand dunks that's the
reason I succeed and then I had an
Eminem poster yeah
I did that's why you are the way you are
yeah [ __ ] it was in one of his first
albums he had this really cool poster of
him in front of like a red Chevy and he
actually looked really cool like now he
looks I don't even know seeing you as a
kid I would have thought you had a kiss
a kiss a kiss pose don't you just
because it looks like I'm wearing the
shirt of somebody that works at medieval
times and I'll need you to come here
interesting story all right so what
posters did you have on your wall in
middle school so I ain't really have
posters I had like the little printed
out versions like start off with Google
mm-hmm like so it was me and my cousin
my older cousin had him like I still got
the pictures is he still got him up up
and his were like in his room Bob
Sanders and tone but they all those like
the great safety those corners we have a
kid people at here of a connection to
him from Bethea if you'd like to meet
him think they can probably good man
good man like he don't like year 16 you
a long time yeah we talked about this
before like the rowdy lots and all that
stuff
who was the guy that you grew up not
liking got to be like a cover scouted
that just it wasn't into hidden was more
of a covers I hope he hated wide
receivers his whole life guys that go
across the middle and talk trash loudly
I said lure anymore really love
everybody did yeah of Cour not that's in
the game Antoine Bethea is the answer
Brian Westford what voice should
Westbrook use here Adam oh oh that's a
great one do my voice yeah
alright guys ran out of cigarettes
earlier what thing has a fan said to you
now everyone just think about this think
deeply hmm came up with this last night
um what thing is a fan said to you in
public or on social media that you've
never forgotten and just take some time
to thinking come back to us with some
answers cuz I'm gonna [ __ ] drill you
about it all of it sooner or later
Thank You Bryan so I don't smoke
cigarettes or smoke daddy cigars but yes
and so has anyone ever said anything to
you on social media or a tag
that was either really funny and you
never forgot it or was like cut you deep
in the fields and you never forgot it I
got a message not too long ago and the
guy was like pretty much you put this on
social yeah What did he say to you so he
basically said like when I got drafted
he was like if you don't stop hitting
people hard your career ain't gonna even
have a good you have a long career
you're gonna be hurt you gonna be out to
lead like that and he was like you
dumbass I come back so I got hurt he
coming back he was like I told your dumb
ass you're gonna be gone I look at you
now and career almost over hope they get
rid of your ass no that's crazy
and so I posted it it's the right thing
to do hey he got coming Wow yes about
that listen the Raiders fan do not play
no account like two hours playing for
the Raiders
he had a Facebook page so fans singing
to me he deactivated his Facebook page
damn yeah he had a backup a like a
business page he deactivated that damn
that's pretty cool actually that's the
power of Raider Nation it is first place
in the league to play but also it's like
the number one thing I say to people is
like you don't need to fight your own
Wars you don't just put it out there and
everybody else do so I had this thing
when I was when I was in Louisville
Kentucky and I was a sports anchor and I
started going viral a little bit by
weaving in like 40 rap references or 40
WWE references and all that and there
was one sportscaster
that tweeted at me and said you're
making a mockery of the profession what
you're doing like you're not doing the
news well wha and I said you know what I
don't even want to do nothing retweet
and like 60 people were fighting this
guy not even Raider Nation but 60 people
you don't need to go back and forth oh
really Wow
people will go there a [ __ ] don't
worry about it yeah yeah but like the
one thing I will say is didn't hate you
can never win never ever no no no no no
you can't
that's one better you can't win that's
undefeated so either all they do feed
undefeated under or at or at a game
something someone said to you and it can
be something funny things two things
two things positive and negative first
I'll give the negative one so leaving
the pro-bowl on the way back to the
plane I'm tired been partying all week
long game goes on and so people want you
know you're you want a one autographs on
a campout and they know exactly when
you're coming I had no guy left I
literally left the stadium went straight
to the airport so they're there and I'm
shocked my first time in the Provo so
I'm like I'm I'm tired got 30 people
with me let's just go probably Westwood
let me get an autograph and I was like I
just blew him off I know you effing hear
me let me get an autograph and I'm just
like whatever and so that's why your
sorry ass is gonna get hurt next year
and you're a bum and you never were that
good and it's the same dude they're just
wanted my autograph and so I bet hurt me
ya don't wish you want me to get hurt
and so my property that's the worst
thing like a fake and like try to do
like I hope you gonna get hurt like this
is my livelihood this how I make my
money is how I would take care of my
family so that was just kissing my ass
talking about you want if you wanted my
autograph now you I'm the you know
what's your boy do are they you know
they roughed him up a little bit but
that's just good all right so what was
the good one the good one so a couple
years back to get his email actually was
on social media so his DM he was like
listen my daughter's graduating high
school college whatever it was he said
but you said something to were back in
no seven he said I was at a signing that
whatever you were at chikki and Pete and
you said something to her and you
whispered in her ear and I don't know
what it was it wasn't a - she just
graduated that she told me and from that
time she was getting average grades and
since that time she got good grades and
she said he said for some reason I asked
her at the graduation
what did what happened it kind of turned
a corner how did you start getting good
grades he said well remember that time I
went to go see Brian Westbrook you
talked to me and what he said to me was
try harder at school be a better person
and never allow yourself to be average
keep pushing yourself to be the best and
she said I took that to heart and every
day since then I worked my butt off to
be the best I can be and I was like well
you hear stuff like that because listen
as athlete you feel good ended up being
Michelle Obama stop you say things to
people all the time like you know me
he's gonna soon you know
not not that it's not meaningful because
you believe it but at the same time you
don't know there's no Ellison yeah you
don't know it's gonna impact and said oh
you know with the platform now and with
the way social media is you got you got
more you know you can reach people more
you have a second impact but man one
thing I will say like these fans man is
crazy like like that situation right
there like I see that on a daily basis
like like I sing on something like oh
Dale shook a kid's hand like the kid was
crying hey how'd that LeBron video where
the kid the kid was like any in the
bronz like don't let them see you cry
walks away and the kid just looks at the
camera he's like holy crap yeah and it's
sometimes as athletes you don't even
realize you realize the power you have
what the impact you have on some people
when I was young I'll never forget this
I used to watch videos of Michael
Jackson performing and in the crowd same
thing - it was grown men our age
crying like little babies for my Khmer
that's that's the power that's the thing
is is power then I always thought it was
because like when people saw the Beatles
they had never really seen the Beatles
before like they're in America like one
time in four years whatever it is and
now I feel like we have so much access
to people's different that now people
come up to me and they already know so
much about me they feel like they know
you and and so it's I always thought it
would be less starstruck and obviously
compared to you guys but like people
come up to me and be like how was that
steak the other night and I'm like oh I
put that on [ __ ] that's right that's
right you know I mean in the creepy yes
especially when they don't follow you
but then you look and they see that
they've looked at all your stories so
yeah you're like the old girlfriends
that's right I'm pulling what voice is
the next girlfriend my DJ's not do my
dice Mike Tyson yes might I be perfect I
mean plane crash into a desert island
you try it with a Antonio Brown and
vaunteth perfect which guy do you team
up with to survive you try where you
trapped on a deserted island with
Antonio Brown bunt is perfect I'm gonna
eat your children
which guy do you team up with - survivor
fine - anta's because if he down eating
he got more meat yeah I put this in here
because it was gonna allow us to talk
about a Antonio but also vantes when we
were talking you always referred to him
as big bro
yeah and when I watched the first few
games the announcers always kept talking
about how mature of an tez was and how
the coaching staff is like made him a
captain all that stuff and then when
they hit happened on Jack Doyle which
was really bad and it was not and he has
a track record the well that hit worse
than the one from the guy from the bay
trees yes because I believe that Jack
Doyle was that he worked in the one from
the guy from from the Eagles yes the
biggest issue with barfi is on the track
Marysol right so let me hold let me
finish this before you keep doing this
because this is his thing that he likes
to do is is is Nick Posner better than
okay but then everybody went screw this
guy pitchforks every former player was
like this isn't allowed every
commentator was like get them the hell
out of here suspended for the year what
is it that you guys know about Vaughn
tez but we don't have you heard any like
I mean everybody want to say he has a
track record if a guy is like dirty guys
are gonna speak out on him you haven't
heard in a half Jon over the years he
was twisted ankles you know what I mean
I remember the tight end back then
whoever that was that might have been
Zach Ertz
he's out there complaining about it it
hasn't been a silo minority of people
now reacting what's your next point I
mean I'm you know kinda I'm just having
I was like with social media now you
know guys like goodnight you know if he
wanted him out delete you know these
guys will come out and pretty much just
say no one has done it I mean it's just
well I don't I don't know I don't know
if guys will come out and say take his
livelihood from him I think they were
like hey man you shouldn't hit people
like that but I wouldn't I would never
come out and say even if it was Burfict
that hit me and be like man they said
they should suspend him forever he
should never play again because at the
same time he got to make money for his
family the same way I do
and I don't want them to be suspended
forever how
I believe that he should be disciplined
that's my opinion when I watch the play
and I suffered I had two concussions my
last year in Philadelphia two documented
ones and probably playing more before
that if i watch the hit I'm saying well
he Lord he had a chance to hit him with
his shoulder had a chance hit him with
his chest had a chance to just hit him
with his face man but he lowered his
head hit him with the crown of his
helmet that's the part that you're like
all right if we're talking about safety
that's where you gotta you got to draw
the line somewhere all right so then
Adam kept saying he was on his knees he
tried to get up he was about to get up
until he saw one two and he tried to
fall back down yeah saw me it's like I
understood you're not really defenseless
anymore once you look at me but what
about the poor looking out with him his
helmet that's the part yeah I mean that
me you know you know you got to keep it
here to you I see ask any of guys can't
see him so what is he like as a person
he's like really like one of the nicest
guys ever look what do you mean by nice
give an example of a nice thing he's
done I'm sorry he took you underneath
you yeah cuz you guys played a game the
same way I'm doing this to have a
conversation I'm not doing this to be
antagonistic yeah no yeah but not like
it's not like a matter of like you know
like my first fine you know I got fine
for you know they say leaving with my
head and you know he offered to help me
out on it but they dropped the fine
because I didn't leave with my head hmm
but I mean just stuff like that you know
and then on top of that you know he
helps guys you know like studying they
play book stuff like that like he's like
what you know like the team talks about
is one of our leaders yeah how big was
that for the defense to lose him for the
year I mean it was major because you
know he he knew the defense in and out
cuz he had been anything since he you
know he made all the chicks like he know
how to get us into the right plays I
used to was out there like and he was
like he was running up and down the line
being like if they're going left like
Denver oh my everything in Denver he was
calling plays out like a a yeah I run a
power right here and I knew he knew the
plays because after the play would be
over somebody else would make the tackle
tomorrow or you and he would already be
on the other side of the line looking at
the other side list the team like Denver
like no no like he knew the whole play
and as
because he's played so much like his IQ
for the game is like Craig's making the
checks now who's the who's the headset
for the Raiders now to hear why here
mm-hmm how's he doing he's pretty good
yeah yeah I mean he's not the same as
perfect but I mean you know he's he's
doing the best he can it's very cool
linebacker is there anybody on this
defense that the public doesn't know
about that is going to be really good a
max max max rookie the guy that broke
his arm again yeah what's his last name
Matt max Crosby Annie can rap yeah he'll
kill you what he would kill you I would
tear him up we both kill you know and
what would it be like to hang out with a
Antonio Brown did you ever spend any
time with him he's like he's like
probably one of the coolest guys you
know how was that for you to experience
your first year in the NFL and this I
mean book something that we've never
seen but the media has like their own
image and how they portray him like he's
like a like one of the coolest guys you
ever meet by UV we portray him if you
came in and you burned the bottom of
your feet off in a cryogenic chamber and
you dyed your mustache blonde and then
you called your happy proper listen I
would go John are you okay listen it was
funny we were talking about this he was
like if we made it to the playoffs or
the subo he was thinking about
convincing everybody to die so like
you're telling me if the Raiders won the
playoffs Antonio was gonna go everybody
have blond mustaches he's won the guys
when he come in like smile on his face
you know he's ready to work right yeah
you know what all this what goes on on
the outside world when he in there
between the white line he's crazy he's
focused on that one hard knocks is dead
the day he came back wherever he was
that he came back everybody
yes came to embrace him everybody was
like hey I mean I think it's two things
I think one obviously you think you want
that type of talent of your team - I
think he's just a good dude but he like
the outside of a different of you know
like he come around like big old smile
on his face like yeah did Trent Brown
handle it well because I know those guys
were somewhat close I mean yeah I mean
at the end of the day you know he's
Nick's man another house hunter Renfro
doing
what's he like as a person as you kind
of know him a little bit yeah little
baby hands but you know everything has
anything hey John good to see ya
good to see a pal he's the Kirk Cousins
of wide receivers
oh yeah he's like probably one like that
were you there for the day that may I
can Antonia got to fight no I was there
for today Andy and tio Gao from fight
yeah and it was epic
oh it was it was voice should he do this
in Patrick mahomes Kermit the Frog yeah
yeah yeah but he's so so compared oh
yeah cha-cha how you're doing it
but Jennifer Playa will look funny as we
mark David here good now you guys have
to make fun of that haircut of me you
have you own the team you see him come
out for practice
yeah I wouldn't be able to practice if I
see that I want to win the Super Bowl
just so that everyone gets on stage and
messes with his hair yeah that's the
only reason I'm rooting for you
he doesn't think so what NFL player if
they had bark Davis's haircut would it
look the funniest like in Dhamma
consumer gaiety and I'm gonna put this
up to the 33% if you guys want a
Photoshop some of these I'd love to see
him some place them to the left go show
and Jonathan Abram won and the 36
Westbrook so Tom Brady and Mark Davis
haircut Bill Belichick in our faces
oh I would love to see Andy just because
that's my guy Odell Odell would be JJ
Watt would look like Oh max no Hopkins
what's the guy that goes I have to crush
he was a cartoon Ralph Ralph
Ricky J if JJ Watt had Mark Davis
haircut he looked like wreck-it Ralph if
you had a conversation with him who mr.
Davis yeah he's like one the nicest guys
ever what did he say anything that did
you say anything to him that he laughed
at no nice is always you know
you know tell me nearly counting them
yeah yeah but you know he's like I said
probably nicer on why you were talking
to him are you looking as I were just
staring at his hair cuz I would have
been looking at his hair like come on
bruh this this has to stop
whatever this is has to stop immediately
we can say this don't say this he got a
funny good but he simply and easily got
some oh that's true too now that's true
who are we putting up there with really
yeah but some people yeah he expiry
you want to do a hint you know it's
gonna give me a give me a conference see
right up 1600 on this podcast Jonathan
Avram just called out who's the wide
receiver for the Niners debo no the one
what voice is he doing this head I think
you should do this in an English accent
Dante Pettis Dante Pettis is weird what
Oh me neither
no no you're doing you're doing a
British accent I used to same Dante
person hello mate yeah I love is that
hello mate is Prospero yesterday he said
that is London is it yes that's it I'm
going see it'll help me out yes hello
love all right here we go
cheerio sir do you sound like you from
all my accident sound the same just wait
till I get to the mid-part it'll sound
like a Spanish guy oh this is a weird
question yet it's a long word till if
you have to be haunted by a ghost for
the rest of your life how could you
choose which person which dead person it
would be who would you choose as your
ghost so you have to be haunted by
someone the rest of your life this is
the longest question like you get to
choose the ghost who do you choose who
do you want haunting you for the rest of
your life I have a good one
okay I mean it's it's it would be some
women I don't just ah yes I'm thinking
Beyonce I'm thinking I'm thinking a
beautiful woman and I wouldn't I want to
be hard
I want that woman to wake me up every
day like hey I'm gonna want my wife's an
alarm clock well my wife to hunt me ever
you haunt me every day that's what I
want you see how I switch to see that
know where Beyonce came from I want my
wife to haunt me you and your fiancee of
course no but if you couldn't choose
Lady Brian Dawkins mentum is real yeah
if you're gonna be haunted by anybody I
would want it to be somebody with a
sense of humor like I don't want it to
be a comedian know that like they'd ha
me be like boo oh no no Dikembe Mutombo
[Music]
just give me Kevin Hart Kevin Hart would
be good okay what voice am i doing did
we do Steve Harvey last time er no oh I
have to watch a couple of Steve Harvey
Steve Harvey is a good voice to have or
Ray Lewis David Lee Roth I don't even
know all right give me another one I'll
do Steve French Spanish see I like that
one okay the guy from a nacho libre una
pregunta para tu que ha Gaeta that's how
you say player which NFL player gets too
much love I know that I'm Antonio
Banderas but which NFL player is too
popular and gets too much love this is a
hater question
it's a hey is a hating question too much
and I'm not saying that they're
overrated I'm saying from the public
there's not a lot of NFL players that
are famous there's none of NFL players
that are seen as great guys who gets too
much and it doesn't have to be this era
I'm gonna say right now and this is a
little bit of a hater
I know what you're gonna say right I'm
saying juju and I I think he's really
good but there's this notion that like
everything he does is hilarious and it
does not be funny and it's not always
funny and I think though that it's great
that we have NFL players that have their
own YouTube okay so I will have to be
audio okay because like I saw a clip of
him playing Jones it's just like it was
like there's nothing oh they'll can't do
em just like that's like easy so your
thing you're not hating on O'Dell no
you're not saying he's bad it's too much
but there are certain guys in the league
that everything they do yeah it's it's a
it's for mainstream yes JJ Watt O'Dell
juju I could see that paddy mahomes he
deserves it he's pretty he's a really
good quarter of it but it's like here
throw a deep pass and just like you're a
quarterback could never yeah well no
here's the thing he's making these
behind the facts know the fans there's a
lot of guys that can do that you
wouldn't ride in a game you would that's
my point
not like that right there I'd be in
there watching it up yeah like the one
that got me the other day would he
rolled it out he looked back to check to
see if it was a play yeah
thank you going were you there no you
weren't there for the Raiders Chiefs
camp I wish I would what was it like to
watch her to watch him there that's you
in the second quarter frustrating it was
it was a show it was just one quarter I
know it was 28 points in the second
quarter I was it that's it I know but my
thing is with Patrick mahomes is what
he's doing is on the field like we have
this thing it's it's it's comments that
people make off the field that like wow
this guy's hilarious and he's really not
or like Juju's just that guy for me
because he's always doing like a prank
on somebody but i still love i still
think he's great for the game I'm just
being a little bit of a hater I'm being
the old guy I ain't really hey mine is
more so hating on media like it just
kind of put out later immediately over
do it well as I've always said
when
Oh Dell is in a video the videos perform
better and you have to realize that all
these media companies are businesses you
know who's the original crunk crunk
would be doing things that like crunk
hilarious and I was like he just
drunkenly picked up somebody know like
isn't he great and I would but every
time we put crunk on Instagram it
outperformed all the other videos never
forget that media is a business never
forget that they're trying to sell [ __ ]
and so right now they love the salmon
salmon salmon salad
oh yeah and they're gonna keep feeding
into that [ __ ] but it's media simple but
what's not simple is the cup the cup all
right oh you're gonna dude last to know
just do one okay and you're gonna do an
auctioneer done about that if I bet if I
voted for that if you had two animals to
make one new animal what would you make
so you're gonna combine two animals to
make one super awesome Aaron yeah all
right Westbrook what are you doing in
the tiger pretty simple a lot I hear
like her you combine them is the best of
both worlds I believe it's happened of
course has happened yeah like been there
awesome I would combine like I'd rather
do like an eagle and nice like a komodo
dragon oh so you want something that I
can't spit and spit acid but it can fly
I don't know if come on oh they're just
like they occasionally eat people they
spit acid too like they said love is
like acid really
yeah there's a lot has a lot of germs in
it come down yeah I would love that
I would love a bear and a lion together
like a lion that could stand up on his
hind legs way there buyin a by hand yeah
yeah
I want to buy in like me and him talk
about it
we cuz she's a Nigerian I want to
combine monkeys and lions ooh a lion
that can climb trees
yeah no one could ever get away from a
lung key yeah lucky monkey because I'm
Jewish and she's Nigerian so we've
decided we're either gonna be nigh Jews
or Jew giri ins
think we like Niger's jiu-ge you like
Georgie reans I don't know Niger's by
the way I haven't eaten or had a drink
at all today because of Yom Kippur do
you know what Yom Kippur is do you mean
like no water nothing I haven't had
anything really was that so Yom Kippur
is a Jewish holiday it is the it is the
Day of Atonement so what we do is we
don't eat all day we fast all day to
make up for all of our sins from the
past year so by sunset tonight you I'm
sin free really we're going out so you
don't have to pray you don't have to do
anything unclean you just know you're
really good Jews have been at services
the smoke and they have prayed yeah and
they fasted I just did the fasting point
okay last question give me a voice give
me your movie announcer voice very deep
would you rather have to shake hands
with Baker Mayfield why don't we talk
Tom
you could only shake hands with one
Richard Sherman or Baker Mayfield who
would you pick have at it
Richard Sherman yeah there's only one
answer right I just feel like so this
whole situation got blown out of
proportion
for no reason that you did you're
talking about the same point Richard did
this [ __ ] yeah Richard's the one that
said he didn't shake my hand and then
the media said actually I have reviewed
the tape and accordingly you did shake
his hand but the reason that I would
rather shake Richard's hand then Baker's
hand is Baker has a high probability of
giving you attitude a little fish hands
yeah like not paying attention not
making eye contact that's kind of how
he's always been where Richard I feel
like would be like oh no did you see the
clip though it looked like he tried to
get a little eye contact it looked like
he wanted to shake his hand because
Richard DAP the first guy yep the second
guy he kind of skipped then Baker was
there in Richmond he he didn't he went
no parts up so I heard Richard on Pat
mackalvey's podcast talking about it and
he said that he kind of came in like
this and Baker was kind of
back yeah and it's just it's interesting
because you can be disrespectful in the
way that you DAP somebody yes the energy
we've all entered rooms where like a few
people adapt you up and you're like I
don't know if they want me in this room
mm-hmm
like I gotta get the [ __ ] out of this
room even you dabble co-people doesn't
be like I don't want to be here yes
dying man
yeah well you did that to the fans and
the ditch the playbook episode the 49ers
face but why is this an unspeakable like
an unspoken rule like have you ever seen
guys be intense like around the coin
toss or is it usually like hey let's get
this out of the way
good luck and then we go to the
sidelines it's usually from my
experience hey let's get this out of the
way good luck and keep on moving
especially with guys that she had
respect for that you've been around the
league in long enough you know it's just
a solid dude you don't have no beef with
them whatever it was I don't have a beef
with you what's up you say what's up and
you keep on going because again you know
as much as its average toriel between me
and the other team at the same time we
all doing the same thing we're only
sixteen hundred hundred of us active
right now so you know you know so it's
but there are guys like Baker that
you're like you know what were there any
other Johnny try-hards when you were
playing that you and I don't want to
call him that but like other guys that
were so intense all the time you see a
lot of D lineman like that like guys
that are just like John Randall he's
like that like non-stop yeah yeah yeah
because he looked like he would try to
break your hand trying to shake on was
one of those John would definitely be
one of those guys yeah are you like that
would you check your hands would ya I'd
be chilling I was one of those guys like
you until we get between the lines I
didn't want to even go out for the coin
toss at all we problem so Carolina
you know we pretty get somebody like you
playing the home we play against Texans
and they gotta hop and walk you know
walking out there I respect those guys
so I wanna go out there and see their
size them up a little bit yeah know what
to do know like we here that's what you
would say we
like I'm just looking down like yeah
I'll smile I got my smile on like yeah
come on you ready put in the moment did
like we get between the lines it's just
like free so that's when your switch
goes it's like when you go out there can
you feel it when we go from the clock
here is 1500 and then Balki's often ago
1459 until you zero straight like and
then right when the game is over are you
able to shut it down sometimes it just
depends like who we playing or if some
things are saved between the game like
if you take like because I love [ __ ]
sometimes so if you say why you lying
the word sometimes too so like it was
certain game like especially in college
like a couple guys gathering in mind I
ain't gonna say t get on musky let me
say that they got under my skin
and and it's not because they play with
it's because I hate guys who like if I'm
gonna talk some if I'm a talk I'm a whoa
walk the one over
that's right I ain't gonna just talk to
you and I ain't made to tell him I'm a
dog you didn't get up and tell you how I
just dogged you right so it be guys who
don't do don't make no place like their
tackle like blocked you really well and
like they were on the other side of the
field and they're telling you how well
you got Block C cuz I'm good it's like
my you are so for example like me I
didn't like AJ Brown in college like we
do now but like DK make fi half a kids
for like 20 30 yards and then he be yeah
you're just bumping mom and I'm like you
ain't doing [ __ ] shut up mm-hmm mm-hmm
so like if you ain't making no please
don't tell westbrook were you a [ __ ]
talker when you played you know I never
would talk it but every now and then you
know you got some guys who gets it you
got it you gotta say what you got I've
never forget we played Washington Sean
Taylor's back there and Sean Taylor's
one of these dudes we he would just he
would say all types of your mother sucks
I mean just bad bad me he would say some
bad so many things that now we just have
to fight and so that's the thing like
when they get to the point where we got
a fight yeah that's when you boil over
into after the game like cuz I meant
what I say it like if I tell you I want
to whoop your
like after the game like I'm coming to
find you like I would I want to fight
now let me tell you about Sean Taylor
after the game he oh man good game bro I
didn't mean any of those things
yeah until we play him again saying it
was every game well Bart Scott had that
story that he told on here about Richie
incognito that Richie kept going low and
then Bart was like I'm gonna [ __ ] you up
after the game and then after the game
like Richie ran into the locker room
tomorrow is like I'm coming to find you
like a big boy - Oh Richie the big boy
huh that's why I think your team has a
chance is because every guy on that
light like trend brothers not just you
and I've ever seen my entire life he'll
stand in front of you know get cold not
love that I love that run game which I
fake love love it you got a run game in
a good defense you got a chance again
what happens Thursday night Giants don't
have se Quan Evan Engram sterling
Shepherds about 30 are they playing the
page Patriots our tea you know what
happens you want to see how many
touchdowns Tom Brady because what
happens if they don't Sony Michele any
given Sunday anyway Burke hit yeah yeah
who is the guy that now you've kind of
been watching more the league and
studying film that is even better than
you thought he would be not on your team
but just people that like whether it's
crossover film or guys that you've seen
the Raiders play who's really jumped out
to you they're like wow they're better
than I thought did Deanna from the
Panthers Brian burns the rookie all
right good yeah so what you just seen
him on highlights cuz the Raiders
haven't even played the Panthers yeah
there's no watchin yeah yeah like a 70
yard touchdown last game he had a forty
foam and he's always coming around the
edge he looked to me he reminds me of do
you know daniil hunter on the Vikings
yeah same body but it was young yeah
yeah makes one jump mm-hmm every time I
watch her and Donald I feel like a child
like I he's that special to me maybe
triple team man what do you got did you
guys practice to get to him you did
right did you just watch him yeah
what did you see it but it was it wasn't
something that he did was it you know
because I when we press enough it's not
about
what'd he do he's like probably one of
the smartest de Lima never that's what
makes him so good like so I mean we like
gay gay blocked him like those to her
battling like deadly like it don't ya
they keep going back and forth but it
was just a matter of he come at you he
boo you he bulled to the outside
shoulders and you know he just he tryin
to give you a light little push with the
inside hand to the right to the inside
so to make you think he gonna dip under
but he don't he stay outside so you know
so you only really know what he going so
then he come back with the exact same
move and then he push on that shoulder
if you stayed committed to the outside
and he rip under being interviewed by
Chris long and he said pass rushing is
all about counters yeah and it's like
boxing and and the thing is with Aaron
is he has every move and he might be the
strongest guy on the field at any given
moment yeah so like when you it's it's
kind of like the wide receiver that can
run the for 340 when you're the
strongest guy on the field the bulrush
has always a weapon in the bag but the
thing with him is I think you're right
we we think that we don't give his
intelligence enough credit and his
reaction time because he's able to
counter everything and he is getting
double-teamed
he is getting triple-teamed it's crazy
that he's still able to be this
productive one of the quick is get offs
that you see in football but that that
counter move is so important because
from a running backs perspective their
counter move if I could get a guy just
to slow his feet down just a little bit
I'm quicker to you so I'm able to get to
the next point that's the same thing
that he does yes he's like oh as soon as
you think you had me I got something
else in the bag I'm going to that and
I'm packaging that's the thing if you
think at all he got you he does that's
right
Oh cuz he's already made that quick and
because if you're thinking you're
playing slower so if you tryna cuz
you're trying to hesitate ah yeah that's
when the power comes in what did you
think about to Leoben Peters and those
practices funny dudes Layton funny dude
Mike Oh Marcus and you get along perfect
Marcus is the Oakland version of you
yeah you know you from Oakland yeah so
we got to arguing like the first day oh
because Marcus is not having like Marcus
Fox with me and that's a lot of media
people that he [ __ ] with and the reason
with me is because I will always keep it
a hundred but Marcus keeps it a thousand
never seen people he talks to people
with disrespect sometimes and he gets
away it's incredibly this was crazy so
we out there and so one of the you know
Duane hares like he's like specialist
like go out there you could put a triple
team on him I dare fly he gonna dog him
every time
not only that no one is more confident
catching a punt with like five triple
around and Duane Harris yeah he don't
even move he'll wait the last moment ago
mm-hmm he's the dude that took that one
a hundred yards last year Margo yeah I
think it's the Baraka no no consequence
right yeah and so I was like you know me
he dogged him so I'm talking don't dog
didn't [ __ ]
so mark he's turning around you talk too
much
I said shut the [ __ ] up I told him just
like I said he get the or yesterday he
start walking close I'm like what's up
like you know me I'm ready to go now
about it yeah so he get to talking so he
was like you talk a lot of [ __ ] for
nobody somebody who ain't play he was
like you're at my [ __ ] town you
better do something he was like I may
pay for the round but [ __ ] Oakland he
like braids my team mm-hmm he was like
that's what represent damn so I'm like
you play for the Rays like but he's
saying it from Oakland I'm a true
Raiders fan Wow he came to me I depraved
and he was just like he was like I was
like I respect she was like you bringing
that swag back he was like don't let
nobody fool you this your team homie you
know I told ya he's no [ __ ] he was like
you better stand up and do what you got
to do do like her imitations pretty good
hey tell you like yeah he's so Cali
yeah you better be ready [ __ ]
and you're like damn calm down yeah and
that's him like spot-on like it's gonna
be cool to hear that from somebody yeah
so he was like he was just saying like
you know he was like man you know I'm
from Oakland he's like East Oakland you
know you know it's my from it's like you
know you better do your thing on me on
god it was like it was like man look we
all we all supporting you he was like
you let that swag that the Raiders me
man just like don't they don't nobody
nobody so it's a little bit weird I mean
I know you're getting ready to start
looking in Vegas yeah how are you I mean
you're like a such a great guy for the
fanbase to have
because you really come with us you know
I mean like support us be here but I
mean Oakland's special the black holes
special backhoe special special
I mean I know you already have a
relationship now we got a brain and
black go to Vegas but when you ran out
there the first time on Monday night
football against the division rival
Broncos and you looked at that one
quarter of the stadium and you saw the
spikes and the face paint and the people
wearing your leg it was Halloween but
like that had craziest fans in the NFL I
think so I got the chills and then like
as we like the Broncos are driving down
there right it's like you can hit and
scream like you don't you can't hear
like just one voice you just hear it's
like a roar yeah just like when you're
playing it make the hair on a Betty and
neck stand up when you're playing you're
like where the hell are these people
come from like what job do you normally
have you want Sunday's this is the way
you dress in the way back once on one
day a week was crazy someone be like
financially they're accountants in there
the real estate yeah Sunday face paint
oh so two pair with the spikes uh-huh I
love it crazy that's so that's but
that's their job on Sundays they they're
paying for a great as fans would die for
you that's what makes it a special place
though I agree and you have to try to
rebuild that in there that's the thing
you don't really have to rebuild it uh
you know these fans are sad that we're
moving from Oakland but one I don't care
where we go
the Raiders fans are gonna travel you
know it you know it's a lot of people
that's tied to Oakland but it's more
people that's tied to the Raiders mm-hmm
I really hope that they're able to find
a way either somewhere in the stadium
somehow with like a patch or something
like that
honoring LA and Oakland in this move to
Vegas because I think it's I never
experienced the LA Raiders so all I've
known is Oakland Rich Gannon Tim Brown
Jerry Rice [ __ ] Richard Seymour there
for the end that little Randy Moss a
little bit a warrants at but like the
Raiders have always been Oakland them
yeah and I still haven't come to grips
with the fact that we're gonna lose that
and it's just
I'm excited for Vegas because Vegas in
the NFL like it's gonna be an awesome
combination there's a different level
excitement in Vegas not only that like I
have a lot of friends that travel one
game a year and they always we're gonna
go to Miami this year we're gonna go to
that one be all gonna be vague Vegas is
gonna be popping every [ __ ] Sunday
the hardest thing if I'm gonna be honest
to you is you're gonna get a lot of away
fans that are gonna be like this is our
boys trip this is our trip and when you
think you saying that as far as but the
thing that's gonna help you guys the way
things was think about it you'd think
about how many regular fans are gonna be
the exact same of course oh they're all
gonna want to make the I met a guy in
London in the bleachers that's easy to
London he say he's a season ticket
holder for Vegas he was like me already
he has a suite he was like man if you
weren't at your mom I'm getting the
suite just let me know he was like we
was like three games there Wow
oh he's got money money that's the best
that's people look no but that's crazy
like he's from Canada Wow
he's from Canada but uh I think the
other thing that I've realized - is this
is why I think it's gonna work Vegas
they had the Knights the hockey team
came in and they went to the Stanley Cup
in the first year and the whole question
was will Vegas which many people see as
a transient city of transplants and
disposable people that go there and they
get [ __ ] up for three days and they
leave will they support a team like this
and this city embraced it like they've
never embraced anything else because
Vegas is a city that's overlooked and
Vegas a city that's dumped on and nobody
cares about the people that live there
they care about the strip and nobody
there gives a [ __ ] about the strip and
so what I think is cool is here is the
city that's been kind of dumped on and
overlooked and been deemed trashy for
the last few decades and here's the
Raiders fans who are been sitting there
going we want to come back and we
embrace the fact that were black and
silver and we wear like I actually think
it might be this beautiful mix where I'm
hoping that the Vegas and the Oakland
people can come together and Vegas we'll
go Oakland come on down it's still your
team because I think it's important
because when we've had franchises
changed in the past when Indy when
Baltimore and and all that Baltimore and
Cleveland suits our team now it's not
your team it's our team now and I'm
hoping that I'm hoping that those places
kind of already have teams and they just
kind of switched Vegas has never had a
team yeah yeah might take some time the
younger generation to catch up
especially when they do their web
investments unless I'm involved they're
winning cuz you're gonna have people to
be like I have an investment in a new
casino man listen I just like art
appreciate see swag swag swag all right
I'm glad you came preciate you for havin
how much more media I love to do no
really on no we're gonna join New York
that's good that people still give a
[ __ ] about you yes true anything nice
yeah but I know I speak for all the 33%
and ever everyone that listens
it was so cool to see the draft and and
like you come in here beforehand and
then you end up going to the Raiders and
be a first-round pick and it's been so
cool to watch hard knocks and you call
in there and and do your thing and just
be you and the thing that's great about
you is the people that matter are the
people that people love and people upset
because it means that like you're just
speaking your truth I know you're not
gonna stop that you're always gonna have
our support you're the [ __ ] man bro
you know what I think is crazy I came on
your show and I talked about some of the
guy that I thought were gonna be really
great pros and they tried to be my
teammate Jimmy shakeups
and Cleveland Cleveland Farrell that's
[ __ ] wild this podcast has magical
powers right is winning the Super Bowl
okay okay poor Jonathan Abram for Brian
Westbrook the Rocket Man yes to say oh
the chest the rocket the rocket you need
a catchphrase for Jonathan Abram say
Thank You Jackie
Jack man we will hollow you guys later
peace out homies
[Music]